This pretty and useful braid is
easy to knit on the machine.
Use tuck stitch for texture
over a few stitches.
Cast on an odd number of stitches
and knit a few rows and hang some weight.
Set your carriage to hold.
If you're not familiar with the hold
setting on your machine, check your
manual and watch the video at knititnow.
Com/HOLD.
Pull the center needle all the way out.
Knit four to 6 rows,
holding that center needle.
Notice how loops are formed
over the held needle.
Cancel hold and knit two rows.
Continue this sequence for the
desired length of your braid.
Depending on your machine and your chosen
yarn, you are limited to the
number of rows you can hold.
Those loops stack up and may
be difficult to knit.
You may need to add extra weight with your
fingers or claw weights so
the stitches knit off correctly.
Try different row counts
and see what works for you.
Here is a pretty variation.
In this example, I cast on nine needles
and held two stitches for six rows.
This makes a wider braid
with a pretty scalloped edge.
Both sides are interesting.
Here's a five stitch braid
on a standard gauge machine.
Holding with the Russell levers
on a Silver Reed machine creates manual
tuck stitch for the texture of this
braid. No
matter what machine you use,
I hope you'll play with the technique
to create a fancy braid of your own.